[Musique]
louis n'a la pluie s'est pas trop
désagréable que pas encore l'écart est
trop saunier en a eu des tempêtes de
neige ce concours se balade on va
souvenirs l'otan de l'halloween 2019
quand une météo capricieuse a poussé
plusieurs municipalités un peu partout
au québec a recommandé aux parents de
reporter la collecte des bonbons
une réaction jugée excessive par bien
des parts est vous n'avez besoin ton
expertise de des lumières la première
question qu'on a envie de te poser
comment ça se fait que c'est si
difficile d'interpréter de lire les
bulletins météo mais c'est parce que la
météo c'est la science et de la science
ça une terminologie propre à elle-même
un jargon un jargon effectivement et
puis on peut pas galvauder ce jargon là
ce qui arrive parfois
j'allais dire souvent qu'il arrive
parfois je vous donne un exemple très
simple on lit 40% de possibilités
d'averses pour aujourd'hui 40% ont c'est
vous et moi que c'est pour beaucoup mais
si une autre personne lycée beatles a
aujourd'hui va pleuvoir
c'est pas pareil c'est 40% de
possibilités d'averses c'est qu'à des
moments il y en aura pas de
précipitation que ces quatre chansons de
ce carnet au dessus de la fête donc ses
beaux succès c'est important d'avoir
vraiment d'avoir des d'utiliser les
termes crise on n'est pas tous des
météorologues bien entendu gignac
as tu des repères à donner aux gens des
des trucs finalement pour nous aider
quand on regarde sur un téléphone savons
exactement ce que ça veut dire quand un
phénomène sans violence en vient on ça
commence ce jour dans un bulletin
spécial ses taux courts bulletin qui
annonce qu il va y avoir éventuellement
dans quelques jours du 20 août ensuite
quand ça devient un peu plus concret
comme système s'approche ça devient une
veille alors une veille on va dire ben
là bientôt là vous allez voir il va voir
mettons beaucoup de pluie et beaucoup de
vent beaucoup de neige
ça commence à cerner on commence à voir
arriver le système et quand le système
est vraiment très proches et qu'on
entrevoit par exemple de grandes
quantités nash et locke ça va tourner en
investissement par exemple si je vous
donne qu en hiver on a un avertissement
de neige mais on regarde la définition
d'un avertissement neige ces 15
centimètres ou plus en moins de douze
heures
l'avertissement tempête hivernale c'est
plus de neige en plus de temps 25
centimètres en moins de 24 heures mais
accompagnés soit devant soi de temps
extrêmement froid soit de poudrerie et
environnement canada est la seule source
la seule ressource en fait qui est
capable d'émettre un avertissement
c'est officiel c'est la seule source
mais météomédia va prendre les
avertissements de tornades
il ya une source fiable en météo est ce
celle d'environnement canada puis pour
émettre en tout cas des avertissements à
l'éveil des bulletins spéciaux et tout
au long de ta carrière rêve
j'imagine qu'ils étaient dû vivre ou
voir des justement des dérives de cette
incompréhension là des phénomènes météo
les gens veulent savoir longtemps
d'avancé on est lundi wei le week-end il
va te faire beau jeu tu pars faire
moi je peux donner l'idée que la
prévision à long terme par exemple d'un
du beau temps pour la fin de semaine
mais rendue jeudi vendredi
si ça changeait vienne pas me dire on
s'est trompé le système par exemple
notamment à montréal ou à québec ça
vient souvent de loin ça va passer les
prairies sont venteuse qui sont ceux qui
a pas trouvé montagne ça va arriver dans
les autres des grands lacs et à la porte
de méditer qui vient de là c'est pas
parce que c'était ce temps là il ya cinq
jours dans l'ouest qu'on va voir
exactement le même temps ici ça ça me
fait passer à ses manches et grands
titres de journaux là qu'on voit souvent
la proche de l'été au divin au cette
année l'hiver va être comme ceux-ci sli
l'été va être comme cela sera plus à ce
que tu nous dis on peut pas se la
célèbre pour moi ça c'est comme
l'horoscope
c'est comme lire l'allemagne c'est comme
je le dit la météo si vivant donc ça se
peut que ça modifie faut juste faire
attention aussi quand on regarde les
prévisions de regarder la bonne source
une ambition pour ne pas être bien pour
s'assurer qu'est ce qu'on regarde bien
aussi sur l'environnement et voilà tout
le monde se fissure la même source pour
ce qui est question des bulletins
spéciaux et d'éveil des avertissements
en moins on part de là la même base
prévu